New research shows that the couple who sleeps
together, stays together!
Hey guys, Tara here for Dnews - and I don’t
think I’m alone when I publicly declare
that cuddling is awesome.
It’s warm, it’s soft - and according to
new research, it’s good for your health
AND your relationship.
A 2009 study from the University of Pittsburgh
found that women in long-term, stable relationships
tend to fall asleep more quickly and wake
up fewer times during the night, than women
who are single or in unstable relationships.
Other studies, in recent years, paint a different
image - saying that both men and women move
around more when sleeping together.
But according to Wendy Troxel, a psychology
professor at the University of Pittsburgh,
the psychological benefits of co-sleeping
outweigh the physical downsides.
The science behind it is still unclear, she
says, but there are a few theories as to why
this is.
One hypothesis is that for couples in healthy
relationships, sleeping together promotes
feelings of safety and security, which may
lower levels of the stress hormone cortisol.
It could also reduce cytokines, which promote
inflammation, as well as boost oxytocin - a
hormone that’s been shown to ease anxiety.
Whatever the reason, it seems one thing is
clear: a happy relationship, leads to better
sleeping.
And vice versa.
A 2010 study of 29 couples, found that women
who had fewer negative interactions with their
partners during the day, also slept better
at night.
And for men, it was the same - but with one
additional caveat: better sleep also led to
fewer negative interactions the next day.
According to Christina McCrea, an associate
professor at the University of Florida, clearing
up any relationship issues can often ease
insomnia.
But what about couples who have different
sleeping schedules?
Do they still reap the benefits of sleeping
together?
Well, it seems the answer is “not quite.”
According to a 1991 study, couples who went
to bed and woke up at different times, tended
to argue more, spent less time together in
shared activities, and had slightly less sex.
Unfortunately, your body’s internal clock
isn’t easy to change.
So most sleep specialists suggest that couples
who have mismatched sleeping times, arrange
a “special bedroom time” where they both
go to bed, spend some time together, and then
the night owl gets to leave and come back
later when they’re ready to sleep.
Another piece of advice, is that couples use
separate blankets if one of the partners is
a particularly restless sleeper.
Whatever you decide to do, you can now rest
easy knowing that sleepovers are doing your
body good.
What are your thoughts on this - and do you
tend to sleep better or worse, with a partner?
Feel free to share your experiences with us,
in the comments down below.
And as always, thanks for watching Dnews!